foreign
[Music]
department store today rhymes with
looming tales and uh happened to end up
next to two teenaged girls while
shopping one of the girls had picked out
a pair of very expensive boots they were
both fawning over them the second girl
must have looked at the price tag and
asked the girl if she was really going
to spend that much of the boots the girl
with the boots said something along the
lines up it's fine I have my dad's
credit card I'm not paying which
instantly caught my attention because
that's not her card I've told my son
multiple times he's never allowed to use
my card so I'm interested to see how
this girl thinks she's going to get away
with fraud but I'd split up from the
girls at this point because they had
found something else we end up at the
same register me behind and I see her
total hit well over four digits the
girl's about to swipe her card when I
decide that I can't let her get away
with something like that and someone has
to parent this child if no one else will
I tell the cashier that isn't her card
but her father's and I'm not sure if she
has permission the girl in the front
turning glare and give me the the
dirtiest look I've ever seen I swear
this girl was going to throw a temper
tantrum right there the girl tells the
cashier her father gave her the card to
shop with uh but the cashier says you
can't use it and then they storm away
and they're very very mad and then she
tells her husband what happened and the
husband takes the side of the girls
insteads is that she was in the wrong
okay I could see where your husband is
is coming from this is like some this is
like something my wife might do
and um
and I would probably be in your house
especially if I was with her and she was
planning on the I would be in your
husband's shoes saying no just stay out
of it you know that's her dad's problem
it's not our problem we got enough
problems okay we don't need to add more
to the plate just whatever it's not our
problem
um so I would be with with your husband
except that what would Propel me to not
want to get involved is is really
indifference it's not actually any sort
of ethical position so ultimately
while you're moderately an [ __ ] for
this it's a Justified
whole situation like to nark on the kid
that way yeah you're kind of an a-hole
but it's also Justified and I and I
really admire it
so that's one of the problems I have I
guess with sorting through some of these
is that I sort of admire people who are
sometimes depending on the situation who
are willing to be a-holes in public uh
so there's a third category of Justified
polishness
that I think is that's a Nuance that's
missing from the a Mida hole dilem so I
guess the final message is that we
should take from this is um
it's okay to be an a-hole but but only
in the right situation
[Music]
here in Canada it's Thanksgiving weekend
and my family is having our dinner
tomorrow my aunt who has a toddler and
is in the middle of moving insisted on
hosting dinner this year despite all of
us warning her could be a lot to do
especially with her moving she insisted
that she'd be able to handle it and the
plan was to have dinner at her place
I'm a baking and pastry arts student so
I offered to make pies for desserts my
offer was taken up and I started
planning and designing the pies for my
family this would be the first time any
of them had seen or tried any of my
banking baking since I've become more
than a home Baker I'm classically
trained in French pastries among other
things and I graduate this winter so
needless to say I take great pride in
what I create and consider each baked
good a piece of art and a piece of meat
tomorrow is the dinner and I was just
informed that there would be no
home-cooked meal but instead my aunt is
going to order Thai Takeout for
everybody I got upset and said that not
only will I not be making the pies but I
won't be attending to dinner at all my
parents are mad at me for not following
through but I feel massively
disrespected and disregarded am I the
animal uh I mean a little bit Yeah I
think you are this is kind of a half and
half household deal so you're the
[ __ ] for all the stuff about how your
baking is your art and it's a piece of
you and trying to impress everyone with
the fact that you're in college I went
to college that makes you an [ __ ] and
no one wants to be around that on the
other hand your aunt
is ordering take out on Thanksgiving
that is that that's a crime I mean that
should actually be a crime this isn't
hard okay Thanksgiving is a Time
for a specific sort of meal you should
not legally be allowed to eat anything
but
the traditional meal so we're talking
turkey stuffing green beans gravy sweet
potatoes Etc right like there's a few
other Staples you can add in some
variation you can add some things in
addition to the Staples
your own twist on things if you want but
the Staples need to be there and again
if you know when I'm Theocratic fascist
dictator of the world this will be a
matter of uh of the law all restaurants
that serve take out will be forcibly
closed on Thanksgiving any restaurant
that tries to open on Thanksgiving will
be immediately shot that's it all right
it might seem a little harsh but you got
to break some eggs to make some
[Music]
well for kicking my husband out of the
delivery room I 23 female my husband 24
male just had our first baby
my husband was so excited and was super
supportive and caring throughout the
pregnancy the only thing is that he
became slightly obsessed with watching
YouTube and Tick Tock videos of husbands
pulling pranks on their wives while in
labor and I just got an idea for a
different series of YouTube videos we
have to do now I didn't mind at first
but then he started casually joking
about doing things he saw in the videos
saying it would be funny I clearly
stated my distaste for them and asked
him not to do anything like what he saw
he agreed and continued to joke about it
from time to time but I brushed it off
since I trusted him and thought nothing
would come of it the day of the delivery
came and I had been in labor for eight
hours I had just finished another round
of contractions when my husband let out
the loudest fart turned to me and said
what the hell have you been eating it
smells disgusting I immediately
recognized that as one of the pranks in
the videos outraged at him not honoring
what I asked him not to do I demanded
that he leave the room
out he started to argue saying that it
was just a joke but I insisted and
luckily the nurse helped him get out the
nurse helped him helped him leave I went
through the last four hours of Labor by
myself since my family lives out of
state and I'm not close to my
mother-in-law after the delivery I told
the nurse he could come back into the
room and he was fuming he started
demanding that I tell him why I kicked
him out I calmly told him the reason but
he was pissed he hasn't talked to me in
a week his mom is taking his side saying
that I was a complete for kicking him
out normally he will defend me from her
but this time he completely agreed I
might be the axle because I know how
much he was looking forward to being
there for the birth of our first kid and
especially when he got to cut the cord
but I still kicked him out and I refused
to let him back in the nurse asked a few
times if I wanted him back in but each
time I said no so I might be able for
kicking my husband out after a stupid
prank that he agreed not to do first of
all your husband is the a-hole purely
because he spent weeks researching
delivery room pranks and that's the one
he settles on Noah fans but you are a
stupid
after weeks of watching all these videos
which do sound really hilarious and I
want to check some of that myself but
that's what you end up doing
just the best you could do after all
that time and all that prep you had
weeks man and the best you could do was
fart and blame it on your wife
leaving that aside uh yeah he's the
a-hole because look fellas
you antagonize your wife
while she's giving birth
and you get what you get well Daddy how
you feel
I feel sorry for you know you about as
much as I feel sorry for somebody who
gets eaten while wrestling a crocodile
it's like these are the choices you make
in life and you live with the
consequences
you knew what you were getting into you
knew the risks and you decided to do it
anyway
and besides third thing
um he's also kind of the a-hole for
being upset about being kicked out of
the delivery room I I've I've been
through this four times I would have
loved to get kicked out
who wants to be in the delivery room
anyway I know I'm one of the only guys
who will say this out loud but I tell
you right now I'm not the only guy who
feels this way that I don't re like it's
kind of gross and um I don't feel a
great need to be there I shouldn't have
gone in there I wish we could go back to
the days where men hung out this is what
they used to do back in the old days
okay they had a smoking room in the
hospital
and you would sit there while the woman
does all the delivery stuff and you
would just sit there you'd read a
newspaper and you'd smoke a cigar that's
right that's your baby and then when the
baby's born you'd go into the room you'd
say hello to the baby
and you'd leave and you'd check back in
about the time that they you know
graduate middle school that's the way it
should be okay the hard year in the
economy means that essential practical
gifts will be in high demand this year
give the most essential gift of all
America's best meat and seafood from
good Ranchers with discounts on orders
of five boxes or more you can save on
gifts for the whole family when you give
a box of good ranchers you're giving
them a true Steakhouse experience with
100 American USDA prime and uppercuts of
beef Chicken and Seafood other meat
delivery companies and even your local
grocery store what they're going to do
is they're going to import lower Quality
Meat from overseas don't give your
friends and family less than America's
best this year not sure what to order
well good ranchers now offers gift cards
so you can let your friends and family
members choose for themselves or you can
give the gift of a subscription and
inflation proof someone's meat budget
for them go to goodrancers.com use code
Walsh at checkout to get 35 off your
gift that's goodrancers.com code Walsh
for 35 dollars off good ranchers
American Meat delivered
[Music]
[Music]